Maybe that will make your intuition turn on. No, it wouldn't
be bad. It wouldn't be bad. I mean, who cares? Like, right? Like
this. This is just non-responsive. You can just say like, I don't
want to answer the question, but then just why are you here?
If the whole thing is like, I don't want to answer this. Then
just say that, >> but don't pretend that you're answering
the question. >> If they don't have any power, if you don't
need them, and you don't think it's worth the the effort, you
should just move on. The only thing that's totally to do is spur
out. Just be anybody but Hutch. You're probably fine.
think he's duplicitous,
a hypocrite, a thirst trap, hungry for power, all of the things
that you say, and harms the Democratic party and sets
>> the psychological soil prey to fascism. All of that
I I agree with. But there are so many young queer, black, brown,
marginalized people in red states. And even though this corporate
Democrat is,
you see it in a long term. >> Okay, so in the chat,
I'm just curious how many delusional
poisoned minds we have.
How many of you think that I have ever shown an inclination to
defend the we just heard? Who thinks that I >> Oh, but
he's got to watch the he's got to watch the rest, right? >> A
agree with his take. We think it's like not that bad of a take.
If you do think that your brain has been poisoned by bad faith
actors who lie about me.
>> Okay, that's about what I was expecting. I think I already
gave a whole thing earlier today where I was like, I do think
he's going to have to go really hard on uh on Assange.
>> Let's just consult the record real quick.
Who remembers?
At some point, I hope Pisco can grow past being like,
just so you guys know,
I am a liberal. I am a liberal. If if his content is always going
to have to be a thousand I am a liberals before saying his opinion,
I really think um it's going to suffer as a result. Okay? I I'm
just saying. I'm just saying. You're like making content for
haters. Probably make content as if the people watching the content
like you. I'm guessing, you know, the multiple debates I had
this with about this leading up to the election. Who remembers
the debates I had with Ogre Boy about this after the election?
Who remembers the debate with Prime Kai I've had after the election?
Who remembers the very last conversation I had with counterpoints?
What was the question for counterpoints? This is before I knew
this clip,
which I've now had maybe three, four times. What was the question
I asked?
What I talk about with counterpoints? JD Vance versus Gavin Newsome.
>> Rump is bad. >> You [__] losers.
>> And so people come and say, "Oh, h
>> Wait, I don't think at least to me the point is not
here like actually objectively you walk into the voting booth.
I understand that's what Hassan is getting asked, but then the
qualifications he does makes me think that that's not necessarily
his opinion. So
in the in terms of the actual hypothetical one versus the other
seems pretty obvious to me. >> Vindicated. Hutch 100% vindicated
as though Hutch and I disagree on this.
As though I haven't used the
hypothetical matchups myself in conversations with right-wingers
and leftwingers. The Vanguard conversation. What the did I bring
up? Um,
by the way, I also said in my tweet that I totally understand
why like more mainstream types or liberal types would be really
upset with this comment,
right? Like I'm literally fine with people being upset with this
comment or saying like, "Well, that's that's
cuz again, I think JD Vance is really bad." And like I I'm fine
with them being mad. I just I wish they'd be mad about, you know,
at the right level. like, oh, it see it feels like you're kind
of underplaying like how bad the Trump administration and its
cronies are, not you hate trans people and blacks,
you know, >> this exact scenario.
And so for people coming and Oh my god, Pisco, what's your take
on this, dude?
It means you're back. >> That is that is my read of it
as well. That is my read of it as well, Porter Beller, is that
he's holding up for concessions. But I'm saying I understand
why this upsets people because he's holding up for concessions
that make them move away from where they think the most voters
are. Right. >> Bad faith sent by bad faith actors poisoned.
Your mind's poisoned that you think I'm a
third party. >> I'd probably vote for third party, right?
Maybe this is in terms of the person making the voting decision
and what they ought to do and probably vote for third party
and what
they ought to do and probably vote for third party.
Now look at this slight of hand which is common if you interact
with um such individuals online and if you watch any of the conversations
I have over even the most recent one. Look at the hand. >> Oh
yeah. I mean at that point it doesn't even matter. >> At
that point it doesn't even matter. What does that even mean?
It doesn't matter at that point. >> It doesn't matter at
that point. >> Like is my policy on this is is the same
as like my refusal to endorse Kla Harris. Um the reason why I
did not endorse Kla Harris. Is there any explanation about why
at that point it doesn't matter? And here is the troing aspect
of it. I think what is being referred to and what he's about
to refer to is this notion that well I live in a safe state.
It's not like I had an effect of the election where they want
to have it both ways that you know we don't really affect the
nature of the content of the election either from an individual
or collective perspective or that we do and we should listen
to us. So I want some people to recognize that conundrum that
problem as it were and that is just like a very different thing
what we're talking about. Okay. It's just not what we're talking
about. When someone asks you who are you going to vote for
I will give you the following. I think it's not a controversial
statement. their judgment on you with respect to who you individually
vote for isn't a
largely reflection of the instrumental value of your vote. By
which I mean your individual votes tendency to affect the outcome
of an election.
We we just don't think that right like if any Trump supporter
came up to you I voted for Trump I voted for him. Would you ever
think like well this one guy didn't really affect the election.
I mean he's he doesn't have a podcast he's just whatever. So
I'm not going to feel bad about his decision because it didn't
really the individual decision of this one man didn't affect
anything. No. When we judge people's votes or non votes or votes
for third party, it relates to one a signaling value, some kind
of value for this person
with respect to who they support and that brings in a bunch of
prior about preferences. So when they say, I voted for Trump,
well, it makes you upset because it signals a preference that
in a contest between two viable candidates, your preference was
for this viable candidate versus the other viable
>> Okay, this guy's got a and we don't like when people
have bad preferences. If you talk to someone who says, "Yeah,
I want to see settler babies."
Right? You might think, that's a call back to our previous conversation
about that baby converation, even if they've never done anything
about it, even if their words have never affected anything, right?
You might think worse of that person. Someone says to you, "I
think women should be in the kitchen." And they say, "Well, I
never voted for that. I've never done that's just what I think."
We judge people often times about their stated preferences. And
so that's one way in which when we criticize someone's vote,
it has such an infantessimally small chance of affecting the
outcome of something, right? It's really really small chance
of affecting something, but we don't really think about the way
that they're voting that sense. We we sort of weigh the preference
that they're expressing. It would be like someone saying, "Well,
I put a little bit of water on the staircase in the off chance
that someone I hated would come in like would slip and hit their
head." And let's say we assess the probability of that outcome
having like happening at like 0 0 1%. But the person actually
put the water there with the intent of murdering the person they
didn't like on the stairs. Not saying the fact that it was a
very very very very very very low chance of them >> I feel
like I've had this exact conversation before >> hitting
their head and the murder being accomplished. We think less of
>> I forget about the context that I was having this conversation
in
but this is like a hypothetical.
I think I talked about this with Pisco.
I think this might have been the example I used
um
that like
disconnecting that if you have like intent
there's something about like the capacity to actually do your
thing that you're intending
uh
people are going to have ADHD tax listening attacks listening
to this but he's cooking I mean he's cooking but you could I'm
sorry you could sit down and come up with a way to describe this
this problem that is far more digestive I get he's probably just
working through
It just feels like this is a lot to throw together >> because
of the >> he's he's just saying that like
I'm going to judge you based on what you want and not how much
you contribute towards what you want what you want right so if
you want you know all black people in the United States I'm going
to judge you for that even if you never really take actions directly
to black people in the United States if you like vote for a candidate
who has expressed that they want to kill all black people in
the United States I will judge you as if that's the thing you
That's that's what he's saying
that like we can judge you. And so probably when Hassan says,
you know, I don't want to um when Hassan says I don't really
see that much of a difference or I don't think it's incumbent
on me or morally,
you know, morally required for me to endorse
Then Pisco is going to say, well, based on that, I think you're
saying that you don't see that big a difference between Kamla
and Trump. And I think that's crazy and I'm gonna judge you for
that opinion. That's what he's trying to say. >> Express
preference. This is very simple stuff I think and I don't know
why I have to explain but apparently do. So I want to say differently.
Regardless of the instrumental effect of a person or group on
an election, there is nothing wrong or inconsistent with with
like criticizing that group, right? There'd be nothing wrong
with that
because the criticism doesn't require us to show that you are
but for cause of the result one way or the other. There's enough
in terms of the expression of preferences
that we are able to come to that conclusion rationally irrespective
of whether this group in fact had a high likelihood low like
uh that assumes that the reason they're stating that preference
is because that is their
and I think there's other hints here that Hassan is stating that
preference not explicitly because he has that
>> or an actual determinative effect on the election.
Does anyone disagree with that? I just want to like gauge my
chat
because the next thing I'm going to say is like this whole like
cost us the election or not is a red herring. I think you're
overanalyzing. He just doesn't do lesser evil voting. Like I
just don't do the thing that we think is good. Right. Like
uh he actually doesn't not do lesser evil voting. I actually
think he's he he's basically explicitly stated he does do lesser
evil voting. He doesn't let it affect his rhetoric.
Right. He's not letting it affect his rhetoric. It's a different
thing.
I think he's explicitly done by voting for Joe Biden by like
by arguing you should be campaigning, not only voting, but campaigning
for Joe Biden. He obviously does lesser evil voting. Okay, first
of all, I'm not talking about what he does or doesn't do. We're
just now talking about what it's okay to criticize someone about
and on what basis, right? But even if this were just true, like
he just doesn't do the thing that we think he ought to do, right?
We're just Okay. You're just begging the question of sorts or
at least you're you're kind of avoiding the tough ethical decision
or I don't think
>> um if I thought Hassan absolutely like refused to do
lesser evil voting, I probably would think less of him as a political
analyst to be honest with you. I understand the argument against
it. I understand the argument he makes like why he's not going
to advocate for it. But ultimately like as he should walk his
his chat or whatever he can walk this is like his way of doing
a tiny bit of like disobedience to show that he's not happy with
the status quo right is he'll walk his his chat I'm sure through
why you should vote for the lesser evil eventually once you get
there why you should minimize harm like once you get to the voting
booth why minimizing harm is rhetoric before you get to the voting
booth is bad to do because it lessens the like the um the pressure
on the candidate to you know talk to to uh capitulate to some
of your demands, right? And then say also, I'll never ever vote
for the lesser evil in this case,
right? He basically walks you there with all of the steps. I
think it seems like he sort of walks you all the way there, right?
Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. I don't think this is true though, evil
Johnny Bravo. I don't think this is true. I mean, I guess I'd
have to see if a significant portion of his audience refused
to vote for Kamla. You know what I'm saying? I guess I'd have
to see. But even then, it's like I I feel like all you would
have to do is say, "Hey, Hassan, I live in a swing state and
I'm really like not sure I can vote for Kamla."
I feel like I feel like that is the point where if he got that
question and he said,
"No, no, no. You you shouldn't go vote for
Then I would have a lot of criticism for him. Okay? I'd be very
very very shocked if he said that specifically
to be honest with you. Like I think I think you know you live
in a swing state. I think that is your vote means a lot. I do
think you should go and vote for Kamala.
>> Yeah. I think it's that tough like do the least amount
of harm. Should we do that? Right. So yeah like this whole thing
about well did we affect the election or not? It's not a way
to insulate yourself from criticism. If there were a Trump supporter
who voted for Trump in California and said I voted for Trump
that dude had no effect on the election. Guess what? We would
still criticize them. Similar to right if someone let me put
it in terms that some I have some lefties and and some um pro
Palestinian people in my chats who watch my streams. If someone
wrote in BB Netanyahu in an American election,
would you think that was bad? This is just for the lefties
and assume that they were serious, right? That they actually
wanted this outcome or that was they would actually be happy
if that were the result. That would be bad, right? Cuz BB bad
if someone wrote in BB Netanyahu. Maybe that will make your intuition
turn on. No, it wouldn't be bad. It wouldn't be bad. I mean,
who cares? Like, right? Like this this is just non-responsive.
You can just say like I don't want to answer the question, but
then just why are you here? If the whole thing is like I don't
want to answer this, then just say that. But don't pretend that
you're answering the question when you >> I just I'm going
to hate this so much. I'm gonna hate this so much if he doesn't
watch the full clip. >> Don't answer the question. Like
if this kind of thing triggers you, you're like, why do we even
talk about this? Then like just go or >> is this the one
part where I want to go and say, hey, this is um this is the
time where I actually do try to call into Pisco's stream at some
point and just say like, hey, just so you know,
I saw this and I feel like these are the pieces he gives you.
I don't really care to argue it though. Like Pisco would basically
try to get into an argument about it. I think >> or just
say I don't answer such questions. I don't answer hypotheticals.
The world as it is is vaccine enough. Do you understand? Cuz
that could you could say something like that. Listen, I don't
really want to talk about that. I just I'm not in a position
right now to do that kind of thing. I don't want to answer that
question. That's a thing you can do, but I'm just going to be
honest, guys. Like this whole about and look s com I know that
you're more you're like you're pretty leftwing. Is the sigh aspect
just an indication that I'm right? Right. I'm right. Right. Let
me answer it for the lefties. Maybe Pat's got their tongue. Of
course you would castigate. Of course you would think it would
be horrible for anyone to write in BB Netanyahu in an election
or someone like Lindsey Graham. I'm voting for Lindsey Graham
or John Federman on the sheet even though you know it doesn't
have an effect on the election. Why? It's an expression of a
preference that you find reprehensible let's say. Right.
>> So this entire time he's just defended the right to
be upset with it
and not like the statement itself. He's he's just defending his
right to be upset with with Hassan here. So this whole thing
about cost is a total red herring and the worst incarnation is
actually over
matter what in terms of his little I think skyrocket 3.24 2104
don't say they're in a shock and grind pretended like causing
existence. What is the implication there by
ogre? The implication is of course this wouldn't make sense in
a swing state but we're not in a swing state. We're in a safe
state and of course in a safe state this won't actually change
the results. It's stupidity right? The instrumental effect of
a singular vote is negligible in either context. And we've had
that conversation so many times. So many
>> What what is this point in service of? I I it's Pisco,
so I'm pretty sure it must be in service of something, right?
But what is this point in service of? In 2020, third parties
totaled 2.2% of the vote and then skyrocketed 3.2% in 2024. Don't
sit there and act shocked. And she grinned as a political content
creator over like this pretending that the electoral college
doesn't exist. It's still go blue. Relax.
Oh, he's saying, okay, sorry, I do have it here. He is saying
that Hassan is is innocent of
swinging the election. Okay. Beyond his vote, even with his rhetoric,
he's like immune to any criticism about swinging the election
based on his uh his advocacy. And Pisco is saying no. Based on
his advocacy like against or his advocacy, his lack of advocacy
in favor of Kamla, I criticize him. That's the that's what's
happening. Okay. I got the height of that faith to keep coming
back to it and say actually I think it's reasonable for someone
to make an assessment and say well I have a 0
0 to a trillion zeros chance of affecting the election as an
individual from instrumental perspective in one safe state but
I have a 0 half a trillion percentage of affecting it in a swing
state from an instrumental individual perspective and that will
that difference that magnitude that huge magnitude difference
between a trillion zeros and half a trillion zeros justifies
my doing one thing versus the other. It is so preposterous. Nobody
thinks this way. Nobody thinks this way in terms of once you
break it down like that. Now they might be tricked into well
it's a swing states are really because of rhetoric but once you've
been exposed that is
this feels like he's just bringing this up to do this doesn't
really affect the um the current hypothetical
he's just annoyed with ogre boy. He just wanted something to
criticize Ogre boy for.
I see. I got it. I was like wait how does this relate to like
the Hassan clip? I don't get it on the Hassan clip. No, it's
just he wanted to go after Ogre Boy for something and this is
the thing he can go after. >> Super rational as Ogre. >> I
would I would agree with Pisco that this doesn't like free Hassan
of any criticism, right? Like the way Ogre boy is sort of implying
here. Like I I think it is fair to say Ogre Boy is implying that
this fact sort of clears his son of criticism and I don't think
that's true. But I I also I also would have just conceded to
that like without any of the talk we just had. So >> or
has been as I talked to them about it to continue to raise it
>> going to speed up again >> try to maintain this
farce again difference between is so not just
now take a step back and think about someone audience now the
bigger audience is whatever now we're not just talking about
the inal of one person we're talking about the internal effect
of an influencer on many people right and now we're starting
to get into well maybe this is actually significant maybe actually
collectively these kinds of influencers might have some sort
of effect on on different situations but notice always it's not
necessary any kind of crak it's not necessary any kind of peak
and it produces the same result because if you're an influencer
presumably your influence isn't limited in the way that is suggesting
here where an influencer who's based out of California is that
their influence extends geographically to the state where they
reside that seems to be the suggestion here
and so on every score
I think probably the suggestion here is that on magnitude like
on the magnitude um or sorry the highest magnitude would be in
California like obviously techhub lots of people watch streams
biggest population center and where he's based so probably his
influence is most in
is likely the point so like this is the highest it And even in
California, likely you would expect Asan to have fewer and fewer,
you know, or sorry, less and less influence outside of California.
Less blue area, less, you know, progressive areas.
Anyway, >> it is nothing but the worst kind of sweeping
from >> I you don't even have to go into further criticism
for
>> that this state difference matters when it comes to
individuals or indeed influencers whose range of influence obviously
extends further than their geographic boundary. I would say this
matters in California for the individual person because your
vote may be in the individual sense like a protest vote. Now
I think
I like
if it's a vote that's conditioned in a way. So he said the BB
thing and the BB thing maybe
but if you just didn't go to vote in California because you know
you had you were busy that day or so. Nah, that's not a good
example. Um, if he just wrote in like nothing if he just wrote
in, you know, or you voted for the Green Party candidate, let's
say an unobjectionable candidate, an unobjectionable third party,
I don't think anybody really cares for the individual doing that
when they conditionally would have voted if it could have possibly
made a difference,
right? I do think it actually matters in that sense. He was arguing
against this before,
but I
it was more he was trying to use BB because it's like, oh, you've
made a morally morally objectionable choice.
So, I don't know. And Hassan saying, I wouldn't vote for Gavin.
Yeah, I think he is basically saying that like a protest vote
in a state that's guaranteed is is still really bad. I don't
think that's true, but whatever. >> But even again, putting
all of that aside, now look at this. >> Was because she
did things that were not only unproductive, but also uncctionable.
All right, this is his substitive opinion on Kla Harris. Um,
you know, obviously we disagree in terms of how much weight to
put on that. Um, and probably even the position of some of the
unproductive unconscionable things, but take it as given for
the purpose of this analysis. Um, but and I still stand on that.
I still talk about all the time because people constantly bring
up like you didn't sufficiently like Har. I'm like I am incapable.
There is no singular >> and this is I think if your libs
are saying this you're the reason she lost. I think that's a
bad thing to like to say. A because I think there's no empirical
basis to suggest that Assan cost of the election at all. I don't
believe it. I don't believe it one bit and I'm not convinced
lefties cost election either either in terms of um I don't know
disengaging Democratic base or in terms of the uh swing. I think
by and large
>> the strongest version of this argument you could make
is Michigan and the Michigan margin was way above whatever the
like Muslim population these really the the people who were like
protest voting on Palestine as that would be okay to protest
vote on Palestine by voting for Trump or not voting at all as
dumb as that would be if you were to take Michigan and and look
at that only okay at worst they lost Michigan and it really wasn't
that tangible the difference that it could that was made to be
honest with But you don't need this really. This in some sense
is not about the result itself. It's about signaling. It's about
preferences. It's about influence or force in this country. There's
nobody is some people I think is a bit of a strong man to be
honest. But some people are saying that and crucially people
who are saying that sometimes are lefties are people like um
ogre himself or prime that push for these analysis. If only right
if only Ken a position on Israel and push what exactly that position
is. It's usually something where I'm skeptical that it would
be accepted by some of these influencers. You know, we talked
all comm have to do is commit to ley act investigations and I
would have promoted the [__] out of her if she had
just committed to Ley act
violation, but they'll set out some sort of principled position
about what they >> I think he believes that would have
>> They should have done
in terms of signaling. They'll say things like she should have
lied to us. All she had to do was lie to us.
Note, by the way, some of these polls that are conducted afterwards
that ask you what it would have taken for you to vote for XYZ,
people are sometimes very bad about
why they vote when you ask them, okay, after the election.
And so, just going out the bat, I'm not convinced a lot of times
by these like postmortems what it would have taken to vote in
a given place. But even put aside, a lot of these analyses only
take like half of it. They're like how many votes you could have
gained as opposed to how many you could have lost. But even in
that situation, even in that situation,
it's people like Ogre. >> Hold on, hold on. Um,
what am I getting sent here?
I got sent two clips. One of them was this one. This is the Hassan
poll clip. >> 80% of this chat voted Kamla. New poll running.
Oh, is there another poll? 80% of this chat has voted for Kla
Harris. 16% new poll running. Who did you vote for? Kla Harris,
Donald Trump, or other? Damn, there's like Donald Trump voters
in the chat. That's crazy. They got people got to be trolling,
right? Vote
in the poll and also hopefully you voted today, but vote in the
poll. Did you vote for Kla Harris, other or Donald Trump? Anyway,
17% voted for other, 77% with 27,430
votes in the chat voted for Kla Harris and 6% for Donald Trump.
That's kind of crazy. I guess obviously we have a lot of normies
in here that are watching because the election is uh is is happening.
So, they were reminded that the election is happening and they're
like, "Yeah, let's go watch that uh young young commentator I
watch." I don't know. Uh still shocking that there's 6%.
>> Uh I do think it's funny that the other I feel like
the other is probably bigger. It's just people who didn't vote
>> and people in here that are like, I voted for Trump.
>> He doesn't say not to vote. I You'd be totally You would
be kind of to believe that Hassan was would go on his stream
and say, don't vote. Why would any, if he was a don't vote guy
or you shouldn't vote at all, why would any Democrat ever go
on his stream?
>> Um, uh, we've officially crossed a boundary for a brief
moment, over 200,000 viewers, uh, and then recrossed it back
down to 187 or 197,000. By the way, um,
I would love to do a poll. How many people are from a swing state?
No. If you voted for Trump, what is this what is it about this
stream that you enjoy? I mean, I think like for example, I have
a lot of haters, right, who think I am a a terrorist or whatever,
or they don't think that, but they claim that I am and smear
me on a regular basis. They would rather watch me than watch
like whichever content creator that they I don't know. He says
this
I do I do feel like he um what he say
that's not the condemnation is that he insists voting third party
until the last second. I don't think he insisted voting third
party. I don't think he ever told people you can't vote for Kamla.
I don't think he ever recommended people not vote for Kamla.
Did he?
I thought his whole thing was he just said, "I'm not going to
endorse Kamla." I I don't think he ever said, "Don't go vote
for Kamla. Vote third party or something." I don't think he said
that. I don't think that's ever been the criticism of him. Yeah.
Okay. >> Are supposed to be enjoying because I think like
they find they derive entertainment for one reason or another.
I try to do my very best to be both educational and also as entertaining
as
Anyway, somebody wanted to link that to I, by the way, I don't
necessarily think that like in in like Hutch's mind, you understand
that 77% he would lose his over that, right? This son is bad.
Like Hutch would lose his mind over that that 23% that didn't
vote for Kamla.
That would be enough to make him lose it. He said you should
vote that you should not vote for Trump and that Jill Stein is
a joke. Pretty obvious if you read between the lines what he
meant. I guess so. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Sorry. Somebody also linked
me another clip, but we'll wait a second to look at it. I want
to just keep watching Pisco's analysis of this
>> I hope he's got the whole clip here that KL in fact
would have won if they had just listened to us
in this modest way. it would have just been a modest
adjustment.
And in that sense, I think I'm being like openly duplicitous
because like it's when he says both parties are the same ad nauseium
for months leading up to the election day. It's just me being
narrow-minded. Did he do it? Did he do it repeatedly months leading
up to the election? Like like I here's the thing. I could make
you believe that really easily and maybe he even said those words,
evil Johnny Bravo. But
given that he said that and the overwhelming majority of his
audience voted for Kamla,
doesn't that tell you that like probably he said some other stuff
in between? Wouldn't that be like a a hint that that some other
stuff got said in between?
Like don't you think
like I realize you could probably find some clips of him saying
something like that? Oh, these people aren't that different,
right? But like I really
I truly believe that you it would be quite hard for you to find
that or figure that out and show like three clips if he was doing
it consistently. At any rate, there should be hundreds of clips,
right?
By that you mean his chat poll of 80%. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, it's
not our fault, but also if you had just changed a little bit,
all of the ideological support would have swung towards you.
You would have won the election.
And I don't think there's any empirical basis to do that, but
it's hiding and it's shifting behind uh using that as a sword
and shield. Oh, like polls as a sword and shield. Oh, we came
through, but also if you had just listened to us, you would have
won. And the way the latest way that ogre tried this in our conversation
was something like,
well, if you had listened to us, it would have swung over the
uninformed voter.
What?
So the uninformed voter would have been assuaged and
leaned towards Kamla if Kamla had put out a press release saying
that she's committed to Ley act investigations of her own administration
implying her administration is uh you know lawless or party to
a genocide in that sense
that would have helped swing the uninformed voter and that's
a way you can maintain this force of well you should have listened
to us it would have won the election.
Uh, do you think his chat poll is representative of his broader
less engaged ratch reach? Um, I don't I don't see any reason
why that percentage would change with his broader reach. Actually,
it might change in a more commla focused direction.
I would say it's probably the most militant people, the most
like dedicated to online, you know, watching online politics
from a le leftist perspective. I'd say those people are the more
likely ones to vote third party. I'd say as you get further away
from him, you probably
like you probably get more and more um like normie, right?
I would think. >> And also it's not our fault because it
was these stupid people who would have been swung or these uninformed
people who would have been swung on this like very narrow
technocratic policy, you know, in the weeds
legal thing.
the whole thing
it just smacks of post hawk
have all worlds
kind of re I this
I don't know how to tell Pisco this
the reaction here is actually unironically ruined by you focusing
on Ogre boy like I'm not you're saying so many things that are
just you focus on Ogre boy instead of just focusing on Hassan
and the like reaction to this clip I don't I don't know what's
going on here. Waiting room. Speaking of Hold
Hold on. Ogre boy is right here. One second. One second.
>> What's up, Ogre Boy? How's it going?
>> so one I'm assuming you watched me and him talk
like a little bit.
So, one of the things that he kept doing that was actually actually
kind of like legitimately confusing to me and and I've never
said I'm good at this and I you had a you had a throwaway line
that I saw in a video where you're like he's like a skitsoid
barbarian willing to go talk to anybody and I I don't know if
that was intended to be an insult or not, but I kind of like
it cuz it's fitting. Like I'll just I'll just I'll give you credit
where credit's due. But so I went to go while I was talking to
him though he kept saying over and over again he's like he goes
well don't you see why libs are mad at you and one of the things
that I think is such a weird disconnect right is well wait if
you're agreeing that it's war crimes if you're agreeing like
if you're giving me this like I concede to you the even if I
even if you didn't want to call it genocide like Hutch is
uh allergic to that word if you at least go yeah they're doing
war crimes well wait isn't Isn't the outcome of trying to shine
a light to say, "Hey, if you if you avoid the iceberg of the
war crimes, like we're we're yelling to a bunch of people that
don't even know any of this that aren't like political nerds
sitting on political internet nerd island."
And a lot of these people are going to respond because they just
know something bad is happening, but they and they just want
it to stop and that's literally the the beginning and the end
of their knowledge of it. So, the voice of Harris on CNN saying,
"Well, no, I think maybe there is something to that and maybe
we should look into it or whatever." Anything in that ballpark.
I'm just saying that was an opportunity that was missed and he
doesn't I it felt like he just didn't understand it and he kept
wanting to make it out like >> you're you're culpable and
you have blame for having this concern and it's like, well, what
the [__] are we talking about now? Like, where's
Do you understand what I'm saying? Am I making any sense at all?
Feel free to sh also you don't have to handle me with like kid
gloves or whatever. Like tell me I'm a I >> I realize I
I'm uh So the way I heard it, the way I hear you, he kept attacking
your tone and the the reaction I had to that earlier tonight
was like not necessarily that you were saying you're happy Kamla
lost. It's that basically you were saying I think she could have
done better. I think she could have done more. See told you so.
Basically saying like I told you so. It's like a little different,
right? That that was my opinion on it. Um
I understand that you're saying that like yes, if she just said
she was going to look at war crimes, I saw a difference between
and I think you asked him to pull up the video for this exact
thing. I don't know if he did. That you weren't you weren't saying
like the Lehey act was important. You were saying if she just
said if war crimes come across my desk, I'll I'll make sure I,
you know, follow up on that to the full extent of my ability
to do so. That's like because he kept hitting you on like are
you saying this for simple people or for like >> you know
wonks or something.
>> That's I I thought you were saying that that thing for
simple people and then you went further because he asked you
for a concrete example.
>> He was like kept trying to hit you with like this is
too complicated for the average person. Sorry. Does either do
either of those answer what you just asked me >> bas? Yeah,
pretty much. >> Okay. It just it felt like there was it's
it felt like there was such a disconnect. And like I said, I'm
dude, I'm not I'm not one of those people that's like I own people
daily, blah blah blah. I'm like, "No, I'm just I'll just go talk
to people and maybe something resonates or whatever." But like,
yeah.
All right. I just I just I knew you weren't going to like I if
I was dumb, you were going to call me dumb. And occasionally
I want somebody that's going to tell me like if I'm actually
being dumb. You know what I >> I didn't watch the whole
thing. >> I appreciate you for that. >> Yeah. I didn't
watch the whole thing, but um from what I saw, I was like kind
of annoyed that Pisco seemed to be hitting you on some stuff
that didn't seem like all that consequential to me. This is maybe
more if you did the tweet like you pulled up some tweet of yours
a little bit ago. I don't know if you were >> but with
that tweet, I do think you're kind of implying that like Hassan
could be absolved. I I that was the implication I got. It was
this tweet right here. Hold on a second. >> Well, that
was before
>> I think about the electoral college for sure. Like I
that was but that was before I even saw the back half of that
I I it's not
I think you could just go uh that guy. But the the outrage machine
that was generated when when the entirety of the conversation
is left out that like a lot of people don't even in California
a lot of people don't even think their vote matters worth a and
if they do vote for president they it's still with an expectation
that like their vote doesn't matter and they're really more voting
for down ballot.
Right. >> Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. I I would agree with
you on that. No, no, no. I agree with you that there's a big
difference between saying like if my vote was consequential,
it would go to the person that like it would be blue no matter
who, but because my my presidential vote's not consequential,
then I like I don't care. There's a there's a big difference
there. If I were to go in the other direction and completely
try to like nerd out in the way that Piscode does, and I'm not
saying he's not wrong because the if you're if you if you get
like hard over voting and patriotism and everything, you're everyone
is supposed to be voting like their vote absolutely matters like
it's your civic duty and your civic engagement and all that.
I understand that's not what Pisco that's not how normies that's
not how normies operate in this also not what Pisco
>> Pisco had an argument before he talked to you and he
he lays out what he thinks and I think what he's saying is it's
totally valid for me to criticize your preference and I'm saying
well I I think uh like a third party vote isn't necessarily indicative
of your preference. It probably it is explicitly indicative of
something in the clip that we're talking about that we're all
talking about. But I'd say for people who are saying that they,
you know, vote third party and I, by the way, I don't think Hassan
was saying they're like, well, I might write in a candidate because
it wouldn't even matter in California. I think he's making a
totally different statement, which is I absolutely refuse to
accept that Newsome will be my guy that like I would vote for
Newsome right now this far. >> Well, I think he's explicitly
saying
>> I also now now that I had seen the back half of that
clip cuz I was at I was I had to do an overnight at work uh when
all this [__] was popping off. That's why I was tweeting
like a cuz I was like bored out of my mind. But this is going
to be like a weird analogy. But I it's He's trying to be aloof.
He's trying to be aloof. He's trying to get some of that presidential
puntang, but you don't want to be tweeting every five minutes
and texting talking about what you doing, what you doing, what
you doing, what you do. He's trying to be like, uh, maybe I won't
even vote. Maybe, you know, whatever. Like, uh, >> horrifying
analogy.
>> But it works. It works. If you're if you've already
if you're walking if it's if you're if you're walking uh bent
over, pants around your ankles, butt cheek spread into the polling
booth, you're not you're going to get nothing out of that vote.
All right. I think I put enough bad mental imagery in your audience's
uh minds for the night. Thanks for talking to me, man. >> Okay.
All right. We'll see you later. >> Later. I just Yeah.
If you
if you have um if you've already like shown that you have to
do something, nobody's going to convince you to do it. Sure.
Jesus, man.
That's true. He wanted Newsome on his stream for a while now.
It's a bit of bait. I don't know about that. I don't know if
it's like bait in that exact way. I think it's
he I think he just realized he represents like a coalition or
something.
I think that's more what it is to be honest with you.
Anyway, back to I think I grabbed a time stamp here. One second.
Back to this right here. >> Kind of reality. >> It's
been a while since I like straight up dis like disagreed with
Pisco on something. I do agree with like um that like you're
I I disagree I I agree with you can criticize a preference if
that's truly what it is. If it's truly their preference. Okay.
So anyway, uh
um okay, what are we doing here? We're continue on with this.
I do want to see if he's just got the whole clip here or if he's
only got the first half cuz I think that's like a part of this
that's really not gone out to people. I don't know why that second
half seems very >> Capable of making or breaking an election.
And if that was real, >> does Pisco address H As Hassan's
intent at all or just more of this? I don't know. We have to
see. >> Right. If it was the case that we could have made
or break the election, which I don't believe. I mean, I agree
with Asan there. I don't think it's true. >> Then it is
the most idiotic thing not to listen to my demands. >> It's
the most idiotic thing. I mean, I would agree, right? Like if
it were the case, if it were the case
>> I got to tell you, Pisco is like single-handedly redpilling
me on
I got to I got to stop just reacting to things in the moment.
Um I got to watch stuff before stream,
right? And then I got to think through my arguments and just
come up with like different stuff to say cuz I swear if you're
reacting in the moment, it's hard not to pause to with each thing
you disagree with.
But I'm watching Pisco's stream
and it it gets to me after a while. And I know I know that this
is my pausing style. That's why it gets to me. Like like I'm
I'm annoyed not just because Pisco is pausing. It's because in
the back of my head I know people also get mad at me for pausing
like way too much.
And so in the back of my head I'm like I need to I need to figure
out a way to like p to chill. I don't know if it's like writing
down my own arguments or
Yeah, we'll see. >> Listening to them were necessary to
win an election.
I would agree, right? Like then we need to stop the fascists.
Like, okay, sorry, Israel. And
here's the thing.
I think the lib should just grant that
if it were the case, but isn't the whole argument it's not the
case? But everybody knows that that's not real, right? If I had
this and and and I I agree. I don't think that's real. I I really
don't think that
going with the Hassan Strat
would have swung the election towards Kamla because I don't think
that they
necessary for a victory there and I don't think that they swung
the election one way and I think by and large the left came through
>> singular force to be able to make Kla Harris as the
president then Kla Harris should be coming to me every day and
being like let me do a collab with you please totally right that's
not the case of course and they know it that's why they didn't
do it But but but but this is why it's a dodge, right? The question
is who would you prefer? Who would you vote for?
>> I think the issue for me is that you have people like
Hutch, like Pisco's boy Hutch,
who would want Democrats to adopt a strategy of explicitly trying
to exclude people like Hassan, right? Explicitly denigrating
those ideas
and thereby like explicitly harming the leftist vote. I don't
know how much of the leftist vote would come through if you were
if you're going out and saying like you in particular. Okay,
you might depress the leftist vote considerably. Would that make
enough of a difference in election? I don't know. I don't know
the math. I don't think anybody knows the math on that. But it
is a coalition that you just get if you're anything but like
evil to them. By and large, you get at least 50% of the leftist
vote by not going you leftist. We'll never let a leftist lead
this party. You Bernie Oon
you right? So long as you're not doing [__] like
that, you probably just get a bunch of leftists. Okay? It's basically
just like, "Hey, if this coalition, if you feel like this coalition's
got problems, just don't talk about it. That's all you got to
do. Just don't talk about it." Just like, or if you talk about
it, be like, "Hey, they agree with us on this. Hey, I like I
like somebody who over there."
It's it's literally politicking. It's like the base level of
politicking. Hey, I don't like this person, but I'm not going
to offend them. I'm not going to make them hate me just for no
reason.
who would you vote for? Not what would be smart for the government
to do, right? Or or the candidate to do. And that's the way in
which it's impossible, right, to have this conversation because
it's just a deflection game the entire time from >> I I
I do tend to agree, okay, a little bit. I tend to believe personally
that if she'd come out and said like, "Israel was doing war crimes
or I'll I'll do an arms embargo on Israel." If she'd done any
of those things, I do tend to believe she'd have gotten fewer
votes in the election.
I think there would have been major problems. Okay. Major problems
for her often times from both sides. But in this particular incarnation
of it, the lefties who just don't want to talk about it. But
I, this is my modest proposal to lefties who don't want to talk
about it. Just say, "I don't want to talk about this." Just be
honest. I don't want to talk about
um moral obligations for individual voters or for streamers.
I don't want to talk about that. It's not interesting to me to
talk about that. Just be honest about that straight up.
But this kind of like, well, it's it's you have to earn the vote.
Whenever you see here earn the vote, whenever you hear it's her
job to earn the vote,
my my mind immediately, >> oh, I don't necessarily see
these um subscription celebrations. I've never seen anything
about Erica Kirk being abused by Charlie Kirk. Evil Johnny Bravo.
I didn't see that earlier. goes to weaselness like
because no one will >> I also just read Porter Beller's
25 month celebration racial slur racial slur racial slur racial
slur racial slur >> talk about that >> thank you
Porter Beller for the 25 >> in in terms other than
somehow separate from lesser of two evils right that there's
some notion of earning vote which is different from
it's good to vote for her so because they don't want to have
a conversation about is it good to vote for her It's this. Did
she do enough to earn my vote? But what the [__]
does that mean other than should we vote for her? Right? Really
try to think about it for two seconds. What does earn your vote
mean other than did she do enough that I should vote for her?
And look at this. And this is typical typical typical for who
often shows up in in my chats more leftwing. We get it. You want
blind loyalty. You guys are all totally ineffective,
right? If you don't want to have the conversation, buy your full
pot. You don't have to, right? Instead, you do the straw man.
Just blind loyalty. Just blind. Is that what people are asking?
Is that what I'm asking? Is that what I'm demanding? Blind loyalty.
And instead, it's
Oh, this is really easy. They literally mean earn your earn their
vote as in something else, right? And that's explicit in I think
that's now very explicit one in I think it's explicit when where
Hassan talks about it after this where he says like oh I especially
don't like this kind of analysis when we're this far out from
an election obviously implies he's negotiating but it's I gave
my opinion and Hassan read it and basically said yeah that's
obviously true. So I think we could just go with my tweet as
what he means by earn the vote. It's it's literally he's negotiating.
He from a from his perspective,
he doesn't like that neither party is willing to listen to his
coalition, willing to like listen to his um his recommendations,
his like his side's recommendations, that they're not taking
like policies from them or anything. And until that changes,
they feel like they should withhold. So that's like obviously
when he says they haven't earned our vote or if if Ogre boy says
they haven't earned our vote, he means like just you being like
less evil than Trump is not enough to earn my vote that you have
to do something to get my vote. And now what I would say is they
can say that. I still think they should go and vote for the lesser
evil. But obviously unless they say stuff like that, there's
no reason to ever actually entertain them or their demands.
If they if they literally say, "Oh, you got our vote because
you're you're not Trump." Then why would you ever have to adopt
any of their policies? This seems pretty >> This incredibly
flamboyant response. We get it. You cuz it's just a motion. It's
a motion coming. >> You should have a private DM with him
if you can. I assume you don't want to debate it. Debate this
with Pisco. I mean, I know I'm correct on this. Um
I think Pisco is literally laying out Pisco doesn't believe that
that's the case, right? Pisco just laid out that he doesn't believe
Hassan is stating a like negotiating position or earn your vote.
He's saying earn your vote means I think this is the best candidate
out of the two, right?
And I believe Hassan doesn't mean that explicitly.
So I mean out of you,
it doesn't feel good to actually clarify the meaning and so you
want to ignore it. The question is not whether you should vote
for her, it's whether he should vote for her. The question is
right the question right now is who would you vote for right
who would you vote for and we're >> yeah he thinks who
would you vote for is a meaningfully different question from
what she hasn't earned our vote is a meaningfully different question
from stating your preference on between two
and it is but I think he has to be leaning towards believing
that people don't see the distinction there right that's where
the mistake is is that your contention with Pisco within 60 seconds.
Okay. Uh, is it a contention?
I'd probably have to think about it. I'll just I'll literally
I might just clip this and tweet it myself,
but I would
It's something like this. Hold on. Let me think of how I should
say this. Um,
I think I think Pisco is I need to hear his exact wording because
I don't want to get it wrong now. Um,
it seems like he's saying like I think basically your preference
between two candidates is the same as saying, you know, he hasn't
earned her vote. He's not quite saying that. Well, there's the
clip. Flip it and ship it. Super indecisive. I think Pisco is
arguing that if you say someone hasn't earned your vote, you're
basically saying there's not a tangible difference between the
two candidates. I don't think Hassan is saying that. I don't
think Ogre Boy is saying that. I think they're saying that if
they capitulate to that on a regular basis, there is no reason
to negotiate with their side to make concessions to their side.
And so doing that this far out from an election is obviously
stupid to do,
right? So I think if you so Pisco argued earlier that Hassan
stating his preference, that preference is something he can criticize.
I would agree if the point of stating the preference is truly
like him stating his preference and not a negotiating position.
I believe he's engaging in like a negotiation of some kind here.
He's he's saying, "This is my position because he believes that
his coalition doesn't have power if they just capitulate, if
they if they do the blind loyalty thing." And this is evident
in all of the communication they do. So, I just I think Pisco
is wrong in his fundamental assumption that they're stating a
preference or or some idea that these two candidates are the
same or there's no no meaningful difference between them. Yeah.
Boom. There it is. It doesn't feel good to actually clarify the
meaning and so you want to ignore it. The question is not whether
you should vote for her. It's whether he should vote for her.
The question is right. You overstate the actual realistic value
of the votes of this particular demographic as a negotiating
tool in this context. Um oh by the way I actually don't think
they have a lot of power to be honest with you. I I don't really
think they have a lot of power. I think their power is almost
certainly concentrated in areas where they're already winning
massively anyway.
Like electorally I don't think they have a lot of power.
I don't think so.
Like there just aren't a lot of progressives or socialists who
live in
Alabama. Okay. So I I don't think they have a lot of power in
fact.
But to me it doesn't really matter how much power they have.
If you don't think you can win that coalition or if you think
it's too costly to win that coalition at the expense of other
coalitions, all you do is you pay lip service to them. Okay?
Like there are probably coalitions of black voters, like basically
blocks of black voters who have leaders who are arguing for reparations.
No politician will ever sincerely argue for reparations ever.
Okay? It is a totally unwinable position. Small minority of the
country, not getting that much bigger. There's just no reason
to ever do it. Right?
But no Democrat's ever going to go Ashley's to say you want reparations.
You leave my coalition, blacks. Get the out of here. You're you're
a cancer on my party. Nobody's ever going to do that, right?
You literally just say, "Oh, well, you know, maybe we could look
into that." And I do think blacks have been mistreated and I
do think like, right, that's what you do with a coalition that
will vote for you almost certainly because the other side is
way worse for them. You just basically say, "Okay, I'm going
to move on to someone else." You give them lip service. You pay
them lip service and you move on. That's politically how this
works. And so to me, yeah, the idea that you just like try to
go after like Hassan or people around him and say like he's not
worth talking to, he's evil, kick him out of the coalition. Um,
I mean, you could do that, but it's just online signaling, right?
That's all it is. It's just online signaling cuz politicians
are never going to do that. They're going to think he has voters.
And by the way,
as much as he can swing, you know,
I just said he doesn't have power electorally, but I guess if
you think about it, in those areas where they do have very deep
blue areas, he could start swinging elections in favor of like
socialist candidates, right? Which I think is his strategy. You
just get this is a Sorry, I I actually said he doesn't really
have electoral power. He could easily have electoral power depending
on how much he's in with those socialist types. Um because this
is exactly how you get the Tea Party, right? So, I I said that
I actually don't think that's necessarily correct.
Um, you you do get like a Tea Party situation going on by shifting
people over to the left and winning some some
nominations and then you get those people nominated and then
you hold people hostage. He's too lazy. I I actually think he's
changing I think um I think Fentes changed a lot of people's
minds, which is funny because I think Fentes changed Destiny's
mind. I think Destiny had essentially no real commitment to real
life politics until he saw how successful Fuentes was doing
And I think Hassan has probably seen how successful Fuentes is
as well. And he'll never say that, right? But I do think that's
the case that a lot of people will see that Fuentes, you know,
he kept saying, "Infiltrate, infiltrate, infiltrate. You need
political power in your country to make any change happen." You
watch that party go further and further to the right and all
of the young Republicans go further and further to the right.
I think this was um
I think this is led a lot of people to reconsider their approach
online was campaigning today during his UBC appearance. Cool.
Campaigning to Canadians.
Very cool. Very very cool. Okay. The question right now is who
would you vote for? Right. Who would you vote for? And we're
trying to define the scope of the question. And what I'm observing
is
a tendency of deflection, which is did she do enough to earn
the vote? And right now we're trying to sus out whether that
is anything different than should we vote for them or would you
vote for them?
And my contention is there is no meaning to that word. It's incoherent
to earn vote. It's a way to >> Well, I guess what Pisco
is saying is Pisco to me is saying that he doesn't think um or
or he thinks either one of two things. That they're hiding what
they actually want to do if it's about leverage or they're hiding
the fact that they don't see a big difference. One of the two.
And I think it's I don't think they're hiding the fact that it's
for leverage. Seems pretty explicit in this clip and others.
But yeah, I I don't know. It see it seems to me to be pretty
explicit. So he's he's sort of basing this on a false assumption
that maybe these are real stated preferences.
Although with I mean I I can't imagine Hassan truly in his heart
of hearts thinks that there's not a big difference between Gavin
Newsome and and JD Vance.
I really can't. >> The should question because the should
the should question will expose
>> uh I also think this is true. Yeah.
Which I What are you going to do about this? I don't know what
to do about this. I It It do be like that sometimes. Okay. It
do be like that, Mr. Stansel.
>> What I think is
>> But also, I don't think Pisco like I think Pisco is
like me in terms of the politics. I don't think he's like politically
that aligned with Assan.
We should not have voted for Kla Harris in their mind or some
people. Right. Follow me here. All right. Maybe I'll I'll draw
I do think this is
incredibly important. Did
earn vote? The lefty response is no. Should we vote
for her?
Oh, I see. Hold on. No, I'm misunderstanding what's happening.
I can't select multiple versions, but I only have classic TBC
selected. I only have that version installed. So, it is just
doing classic TBC automatically. That's what it's doing. I see.
I got it. I got it. We're good. >> The lefty response is
uh maybe in a swing state, right? Maybe in a swing state. But
what
do these two things mean? Right? What does earn vote mean?
Why do these produce different results?
In other words, what are we looking at with this inquiry? earning
vote that is different from should we vote for such that it produces
two different results. Even if this by the way is yes for harm
reduction, right? What does earn vote mean in this context? >> Uh
meaningful change in the direction of the party in a direction
that they like
making up ground essentially towards or making some sort of headway
towards the things they want. Is that not pretty obvious? It
feels pretty obvious.
I don't think that there's anything that I've been convinced
by
at all. Like hypothetically,
the Democratic Party loses all
like, okay, how could we do this?
oh, I'm trying to think of how you could do this in a way that
you'd have to go somewhere else.
Let's say that we had a Middle Eastern
It's a full democracy. I think this is like Tunisia, right? I
think Tunisia is a full like Middle Eastern,
you know, North Africa country that's fully Muslim and they would
have way different cultural norms, but I think it's fully democratic.
And you wanted to vote there, would you always vote for the least
harmful person? Would you always advocate openly for the least
harmful person with no push? like with no you would never ever
say or withhold any of your like support for somebody. Let's
say you have influence. You would never withhold your support
for somebody unless they move towards you
cuz then then I feel like you you're somebody with influence
and you're not trying to put pressure to make meaningful change
in your direction.
You're only you're only advocating for harm reduction, right?
I just I think I think there's obviously and it's like probably
there's there is a world where only
Yeah. only voting or only advocating for harm reduction leads
to no positive change. No positive change in your direction at
all. You keep making this point this week and I think it's bad
game theory.
Um why is it bad game theory? What what's the I you could just
say why you think it's like not true. I mean if you want to wait
and say you have like an inkling that it's not true but you need
like to figure it out. That's fine. I'd be down to hear like
an argument against this. I think this is broadly how every like
voting block works though that they will try to extract concessions
from a group. They will threaten they will withhold their they
will threaten to withhold their endorsement. They will withhold
their endorsement and then eventually they'll say okay.
Like they might give a private directive if they've not gotten
any concessions, but if they get no concessions, I think they
just kind of go whatever.
Vote your conscience. Yeah. I don't Yeah, I don't know what you're
talking about. you'd have to write it up or something to try
to make a coherent argument. Harm reduction without concessions
means politicians can just endlessly lie. Well, the idea would
be that you could run a different politician who wasn't lying
and eventually they would start winning.
But I just don't know that that's true. I think that moves pretty
slowly. And I also think the capacity for politicians to lie
at this point is essentially endless.
Like the way the system is working currently, I don't know how
you work against it. Pretty blackpilled on that. But anyway,
yeah, we'll keep we'll keep >> this means something coherent
other than this, right? Other than perhaps this is ideal, right?
Is she my ideal? >> Uh, harm reduction voting also rewards
the party that is willing to be more
Sure. Yeah, I'd say the overtime window shifts. Yeah, I I understand
the ratchet argument. Huzzan makes the ratchet argument fairly
often. Normal democracy, you just vote for a slightly different
political party. I mean realistically every every other system
descends into unless it's proportional representation which has
a lot of problems in it in and of itself
then every every system that's first passed the post just descends
into a two-party system anyway. So
>> candidate maybe that's what earn vote
>> like you do you think in Canada if you say well I'm
going to vote for like the NDP that liberal voters don't go oh
so you're just going to let the conservatives win? Oh, so you're
just gonna let the kids Oh, so you're just gonna let them win.
That's literally how it always works in >> But really,
when when you have these conversations, try try to clarify the
meaning in this earn vote terminology. It's the candidates's
job to earn the vote of the citizen. I don't think that there's
any
any accepted or thoughtout meaning here other than perhaps ideal
candidate. My thought process is it's a
let's say,
is there a way of doing this if it's not hyperbolic? Like slavery
exists.
There's a cohort of black people who won't vote for you. They
get votes though, okay? They get, you know, it's the three-fifths
compromise or something. They get votes, but they're a really
small portion of the population, but they're a meaningful block
in some
They say, "We won't vote for anybody who's not willing to abolish
slavery."
Is that like
is refusing to budge on that really like
does that matter?
There's there's a better way to do this. Maybe not with slavery.
There's something there's a better way to do this. But then you
have to create the also the extreme pressure on the other side
of like they're going to start advocating for like really insane
I don't know the right to like slaves or something. They're your
property. You can kill them. And basically people are
uh that's probably a better choice is like you watch the rights
of those people go away or something and you keep voting in the
other direction. Keep voting for harm reduction but then the
party that you support like refuses to ever move in your direction
at all. Like you're not making meaningful change but you have
some power to they will lose to the other party. And they're
basically saying maybe this is a good analogy.
you have some capacity to make change, like make meaningful change
that's not going to keep your people like upset and and on a
path towards like nowhere.
You have some power
and they basically say, "Yeah, but these people will like vote
to like allow you to be killed. Do you want that?" And you're
like, "No, but also you need us to win. You need you need like
our help." I think maybe that doesn't work because leftists probably
have like less power. I'd have to I'd probably have to start
writing stuff down. We're at the end of stream. Why am I even
thinking? I should just be playing video games. Hate to get away
around
resolving this should
In other words, a lot of people I think probably including Direfall
who's now losing his mind in the chat, I assume. And
uh yeah. Yeah. Losing his mind in the chat
to avoid this question. Should you? Ought you? Is it good to?
Would it be wise to?
This is the question that libs want answered. Right. Libs care
about this question and a lot of people don't want to answer
that. >> Wait, but obviously So,
what's even confusing here? Hold on.
Okay, my mods are on. Cool, cool, cool. My mods are on.
Also, did this just pop up over you guys? It did. Hold on.
We're not quite ready yet. We're not quite ready yet. Go a game.
>> The question. So, they go to this question. Like this
isn't this isn't even remotely a question, right? This
this is like you you know why libs want you to answer this question
cuz they want you to basically capitulate and not withhold your
vote like at this point, right? This is essentially he's explaining
all of my all the things in my post. I don't mind. I know why
libs want this question answered. They want to know that they
have your like coalition locked down. They want your admission
that their coalition that your coalition should vote for them.
that that is the least harmful thing they could do is vote for
you. Greatest benefit to you, right, is once once the candidates
are locked in, the greatest benefit to progressives would be
to go into the booth on the day and vote for Kala Harris, probably
Gavin Newsome, probably anybody the Democrats have run.
They want you to say that because they don't want you to go at
like at any point and withhold your vote and say we need a concession,
right? And they might even be right that in the long term
the the thing is is as as the other side gets worse your bargaining
power increases
commensurate with the threat as in we really want your vote we
really need your vote the other side's really bad and so you
say well then I have a lot of power here right and you're basically
saying yeah but because the threat on the other side is so bad
we don't want you to do that
right do they though or they don't and you should just move on
if they don't have any power. If you don't need them and you
don't think it's worth the he the effort, you should just move
on. The only thing that's totally [__] to do is spur
out.
That's the only That's the only play. The only thing that's wrong
to do in this entire like matrix of decisions is spur out like
a on the internet. That's it.
Just be anybody but Hutch. You're probably fine. Which who the
knows what that means.
Seriously, I I am
and people who take the view of earn vote, the earn vote viewers,
the it's the candidates's job to earn the vote type people. I
encourage you to come into the VC into the Discord.
Again, evil Johnny Bravo, you were just explaining the leverage
that they have. Like there is there's got to be something here
in game theory that talks about Yeah, I have like a stick of
dynamite and I'm telling you to give me your money or I like
the stick of dynamite. Right. Come to the discord so Pisco can
yell at you.
Pisco yelling at me. This is not yelling at me. What are you
talking about? I'm in the disc. I'm in my Discord. Read his earlier
messages.
You exist in a marketplace. You need to out compete. There is
no competitive value as a tiny voting block with no loyalty doing
what you are referring to.
Um well, hold on. But the voting block does have historical historical
loyalty. That voting block does vote with Dems. Basically, always
saying that that voting block that your error is saying that
that voting block has no historical like loyalty. Okay, I'll
hold on. I'll keep I'll keep reading. Give me a second. One bird
in the hand is worth the bush. Basically, statisticians working
for campaigns have asymmetric information. Why would they think
there's optimal value to be gained according voters on the far
left who are registered but who vote consistently in primaries
but never in the general?
I don't. But hold on. You you've already made like a million
assumptions here.
What do you mean never in the general? Do you think these people
largely don't vote in the general? Do you not think a significant
part of Han's like threat here is I'm going to start campaigning
against you possibly? Yeah. I I don't think there's any significant
block of leftists who withhold their vote often.
I think that's insane. We're talking about people who vote for
Democrats often like Hassan's chap
who vote in droves for Democrats who Hassan is going to say like
we are done capitulating. We're done with the corporate Democrats.
We're ready to move on. I don't know.
I think by the way the idea that you'd vote in primaries and
not in generals, that's there's that literally is zero people.
There is literally nobody who votes in primaries and doesn't
vote in generals. That is a that is a person that doesn't exist.
And if you think that person exists, you are brain broken. I
don't know what to tell you. There's nobody politically involved
enough to go and vote in a primary that will skip the general
election. That's insane. That's totally insane. I know at least
five of those. Oh, sorry. Skip the election in anything other
than like a protest against electing anybody. Like they would
vote third party or something. Maybe. Maybe.
But like that's that's them casting a vote, right? That's them
explicitly saying actually I don't want to vote.
That's them making a decision. I just I thought you were saying
like and would withhold like wouldn't vote in the general generally
like like just didn't care to vote in the general. Not like saying
I don't want to vote because I don't like these people. Also
though, wait, they don't go and vote at all? They don't vote
down ballot.
Yeah. I don't think we're talking about Hassan. I don't think
um I don't think Hassan controls those people at all.
I think Hassan controls people who care about politics. You're
describing people who are like pot smokers who want free money.
Yeah. I don't think I don't think we're talking about the same
group of people. So, if those are the only people you think like
are someone they care about, I I just don't think that's um that's
not Hassan's people. I don't think. And tell us what this means
and how it's different than should we vote for them. You are
losing your mind. You're too emotional.
And you don't like that I'm providing clarity here. The problem
is you should vote for lesser two evils, but saying that so early
makes it okay, right?
This is a way that you could resolve it, Missy. Right. That's
what we call meta,
There's nothing necessarily wrong with that, but it is meta.
It's not not an answer here, right? It's >> Yeah. Uh, it's
not, but it's explicitly what Hassan's doing. It's why people
supposed to watch the whole clip. >> Asking this is bad.
Asking demanding above is bad equals bad. >> Yeah, we watched
that yesterday. Jack's
saying things uh resolving this answering it upfrontly
in the way that I think is bad right but that's not answering
the question right that's a question that's a response about
the nature of the question not a response to the question you
understand now this could be your response be like I don't want
to answer that question because
demanding it this early reduces leverage
but do you understand that when you say that it is a dodge and
I actually would prefer, you know, if Assa just said,
I don't want to answer that question. I don't want to give him
my leverage.
And this is what Josiah like >> Yeah. I think there's essentially
no difference between what Josiah recommended and what Hassan
actually said. If you just look at the longer >> the outcry
wouldn't be nearly as bad because to me,
and this is going to trigger the the libs now. >> Libs.
Okay. So, he didn't look he didn't look any further. So, I think
that's explicitly what Hassan's saying, and you lose that if
you didn't look like further into the clip. Eddie,
this entire story is a nothing burger, right? This whole thing
is a nothing burger. It's a nothing burger because we already
know this and his father has been open about this and it doesn't
change anything, right? Like the lefties in the chat, I think,
are rightly looking to their left and looking to the right like
what's the big deal? And I like agree like the big deal is nothing
because we already knew this, right?